- Welcome everyone to another
episode of Firm Learning.
And today I wanna talk about
how to dress like a consultant.
And of course we all know that consultants
like to wear suits, shirts,
sometimes also ties,
so, in today's video, I do
wanna go beyond the obvious
and also talk about the
more similar differences,
the less obvious things
that do made alone,
really can make a difference,
when you choose your wardrobe
for consulting.
This video focuses on the male wardrobe,
since the gentleman edition,
I might also create a video about
female wardrobe in the future.
Let me know in the comments
whether this would be a topic
you're interested in as well,
I might need some female
support on that though.
The topic I want to connect this to
is maybe a little bit controversial,
so, feel free to provide your opinion,
your views also in the comments.
But it is at least my humble observation,
that in especially MBB firms,
so these leading strategy
consulting firms,
McKinsey, BCG, Bain, and the like,
the quota of people with a
working class background.
So, the quota of people
of first generation
academics is rather low.
So, the question of course
is, why is this the case?
Surely there are no hard
criteria in the interviews
discriminating against
these kinds of backgrounds.
It seems clear to me though
that at least in academia,
these types of phenomena are way describe,
there is also very famous sociologists
called Pierre Bourdieu, who
coined the term "Habitus."
So, describes how different
people have different habitus,
which can be loosely
translated to social status.
But Pierre Bourdieu is very explicit,
that this status is to be
defined far beyond only money.
So, there's much more to it
than just your financial means.
And the big part of it is
also your cultural capital.
So, for instance, how to
address in certain situations
and maybe also how not to
dress in certain situations.
And this is arguably a knowledge
that people with certain
backgrounds may be lack,
because of course, this is not
something that you will learn
during your business
administration studies.
These are often things that
you really learn at home
maybe from your parents, from your peers.
Of course, everyone knows
that you need to wear a suit
a shirt, maybe a tire
to your job interview,
but people often lack the
understanding beyond that, right?
So, what type of suit
are you supposed to wear?
What type of shirt are
you supposed to wear?
So, these are exactly the things
I want to help you with today,
these fine distinctions as
Pierre Bourdieu would call it,
that really can have a
very significant impact
on you personally and also professionally.
So, let's start with the suits.
So, what suits should you wear?
And just to provide a
little bit of context,
I also want to talk about a
slightly more formal attire
and how this fits into the bigger picture
of what you should wear as a consultant.
I think the first thing to understand
is that usually for men's wear,
you distinguish evening
attire and daytime attire.
So, let's start with
formal evening attire.
And there are usually
three types of suits,
dress suits that you wear as a man.
The most formal one is a Tail coat.
So, this is what often is described
as a white tie dress code,
a tail coat, sometimes
worn for gala dinners,
frankly rather rarely really used today,
but that's the most formal attire
that you can wear as a man.
The second most formal, and
this maybe something that
some of you have also more
experienced with, is a Tuxedo.
So, a tuxedo are things that
you will also wear often,
this is worn again in more
usual regular gala events,
often also in the evening
of a wedding for instance.
A tuxedo would be something like this.
Now, we can make just a video about that,
now, I don't want to go
too much into the details
of how a tuxedos may be different
from a more regular suit.
But surely I hope it's
clear, that you will not wear
neither a Tail coat nor
tuxedo as a consultant.
And the number three for the
more formal evening attires,
is a Black suit.
So, if a tuxedo is maybe
a little bit too much
and you are on a very
formal event in the evening,
you might want to wear a Black suit.
So, that's the evening attire
and now let's talk about
the daytime attire.
And daytime usually means
until about 6:00 PM.
So, that's the logic that you will hear.
And the most formal daytime
attire is a Cutaway.
So probably, also contrast
to a take called cutaways
also cuts, as many
people like to call them
are still rather common,
You often see them
at more formal weddings
during the daytime.
So that's number one, the cut,
the number two most formal
is called the Stresemann,
also called a Black lounge suit.
I will likely insert a
picture somewhere here,
because, frankly also don't have one.
And then number three
is a Black suit as well.
So where do I want to get it?
Because indeed, all these things are not
what you will wear
usually as a consultant.
And the error that some people are doing
is that they are wearing a black suit
to the regular consulting job.
This is a typical error, because again,
black suits are usually formal
attire, for formal events,
not for your day to day business,
not for your day to day clothing.
So, what type of suit
would you wear instead?
Well these are darker suits
that are not black though.
The typical colors would be an anthracite,
so dark anthracite color.
Another typical color would
be just a dark gray tone
for instance, something like
this that you could wear
or also a dark blue.
Personally, I really like dark blue,
just in general as a
color and also for suits,
I think this often fits really well.
Next, let's talk about shirts,
because, for sure there are many errors
that you can make with shirts.
And the first thing
that maybe comes to mind
is a plain wide shirt.
So can you wear a plain white shirt?
and here I'd say, hmm, yes,
but maybe it's not the best shirt.
I mean, first of all,
truth is also MBB firms,
so maybe especially MBB firms,
many people wear white shirts.
So, this is for sure not uncommon,
you will see many people wearing them.
But now, linking this back to this point
on more formal attire,
traditionally plain white shirts
are shirts that are
worn for formal attire.
And indeed, so what shirt
do you wear instead?
So, let me just show a couple of examples.
So usually, what's
recommended maybe rather
instead of a plain white,
is a simple light blue.
So, be careful here with a tone of blue,
the tone really matters and
principle, you want to go
with a very light blue like this,
so this would be a good alternative.
Another nice touch is a light stripe.
Something like this, so
blue and white stripes,
this also makes a very
nice day to day shirt,
that you can very well wear
also during business times,
where for instance, you
should be a bit careful
just to provide an example.
It is a shirt like this.
This is also blue and probably
still border line okay.
But notice how this blue
already is a little bit darker
than this other blue.
Now, I'm not sure whether you
can see it well in the video
but, this blue is a little bit darker
and this darky makes it a
little bit more sportive.
And again, we don't
want to go with too much
of sportive shirts in these occasions,
but now let's talk about
patterns of shirts.
And I do think that you
can also wear patterns,
which are maybe a little more extravagant
than just simple stripes,
so let's look at an example like this,
again, not sure where you
can see it in the video,
but, this is a very
light, light blue pattern.
That is a bit more complex though,
with more cross type of things in here.
Why this is very light,
I'd say this is still okay.
Here the point is, how
visible these patterns are.
And again, let's contrast
that for instance,
with a shirt like this
with more very, very bold stripes pattern.
This is too much, this is too sportive.
This is not a type of
shirt that you should wear.
Let's talk about something else,
and this is now the collar.
And here also one very typical error,
and now here I'm deliberately
choosing this shirt
which is already sportive,
is this type of collar with
two buttons in the collar.
This type of color is
called a button down collar.
So, if you wear this, the
first very big four power
is if you wear such a shirt
without closing down your
buttons of the collar.
So, this just an absolute no good,
this is, has only to do with consulting,
but also just in your leisure and so on,
button down shirts are
always supposed to be worn
with closed buttons here at the collar.
But I would even go one step beyond
and to say that, this
type of collar in general,
is considered to be a
very sportive collar type.
So, I would claim that in general
shirts with a button down collar,
should not be worn in more, you know,
formal consulting day
to day business attire.
Let's now talk about shirts
with colored buttons.
So here again, you see a very
sportive version of a shirt.
See how more sportive versions
more often come also with button down,
again, you just fits it,
because, it's also sportive collar type.
But indeed, here with this example
you have these dark black buttons.
One thing that I think
is just, don't do it.
You see quite frequently our shirts
that maybe even white, right?
So white shirts, which makes
them already very formal
and then they come with,
for instance black buttons
or somehow colored buttons.
And I guess maybe some people believe
that this is like a
great stylistic choice,
here again, just don't do it.
So now, let's next talk about
the cuffs of your shirt.
And probably the two most
common variations are
so-called Barrel cuffs,
So more sportive of ones
and also Double cuffs.
So I need to look at the screen
to know all these English terms.
But here the simple double cuff
would be something like this.
So cuff that then you fold
and then put together and
then connect via cufflinks.
So, this is usually the
more formal type of cuffs.
And the other type that is considered
the more sportive one, is the single cuff
or barrel cuff is what
it's called in English.
And that's the cuff where
just with simple buttons,
without folding them,
you can connect them.
Today it's very common to
just wear these simpler cuffs,
also for your shirt,
So, this is absolutely fine,
this is absolutely what you can wear.
To be aware if you want
to be a bit more formal,
a bit more dressy,
these types of cuffs, the
double cuffs work as well,
and then of course you
have the opportunity
to combine this with some cufflinks.
But just a nice way of
having some jewelry, maybe,
even as a man on your cuffs,
now, I don't want to go here
too much into the detail,
surely, don't overdo it
with your cufflinks, right?
I mean, you can be extremely extravagant.
I mean, you'll also choose
maybe some more simple,
more decent motives,
but I trust in general
that's an important
distinction to know as well.
Let's now discuss ties.
And here probably the reality
and also for MBB consulting
is that ties are not that
commonly worn anymore.
And you often will
adjust a little bit more
to the client office or
what the clients is doing,
if they're wearing ties,
then you will likely wear a ties as well.
Probably, the majority
of the clients I work for
that we didn't need to wear a tie,
but, even if you don't need to wear a tie,
I think it's always the
best practice to have a tie
in your bag.
If maybe on short notice, you
need to join another location,
maybe join a workshop,
a meeting, whatever,
maybe even at another client,
that you are ready to wear a
tie whenever this is required.
So if you do wear a tie
similar with the other things,
I would choose more plain,
more regular colors,
so here, for instance,
dark green, dark blue,
some very light more decent
motives, surely, are okay,
is maybe here, you see
this very light green
and blue motive that you
see here on this tie,
but this is what I would go for.
Surely, I would be a bit careful
when your motives are more
colorful, more playful,
maybe like something like this.
This would be a more sportive tie.
This probably is not the
best fit for consulting.
So, let's now talk about
the shoes, because surely,
this is also an important
part of your outfit.
And here, frankly, I would in general
just go with dark black shoes.
This is where you usually
will not go wrong.
So very classical, typical
shoe type like this.
I believe these are called Oxfords.
Now probably, the real experts
in the comments will tell me
that this is not right or
maybe called differently.
Let me know, I'll be interested.
But this is just a very
typical, nice form,
and maybe a little bit more sportive,
are these brogue, since
I believe they're called
also similar with a bit
more appliances here
at the top part of the shoe.
So, this for sure is absolutely fine,
you can wear this.
We won't be a bit careful of brown shoes.
But this to some extent
can be okay as well.
It often looks very sportive
and it require a little bit
more of stylistic command,
to really combine them in the right way.
If you do wanna be a bit more extravagant,
surely, there's also some other models,
like some nice monks for instance,
they can work quite well.
I will try to include a
couple of pictures here
for these types of shoes,
but if in doubt, go for very
nice, clean, simple Oxfords
and you will do nothing wrong.
Let's next talk about belts,
because usually, you will use belts
to hold your suit into position.
Some suits don't require one,
but I'd say most of them
that you will buy do,
until there's one very
basic and simple rule,
this is that the belt should have both
the color and the material of the shoes
that you are wearing.
The color and the material of
the shoes that you're wearing.
So, if you just follow my recommendation
and go with very plain
and black leather shoes,
then just pick a plain black leather belt
and you will be fine.
If you do choose brown shoes,
then of course also choose a brown belt.
If you go for buckskin material,
make sure that your belt is
from buckskin leather as well.
Again, color and material of your shoes
and your belt should match.
This is the very basic, simple
rule that you should follow.
So, last one no list,
let's talk about accessory.
So, what are the additional
things that you can wear?
We all ready talked about cufflinks.
Another big question that I
often get are pocket squares.
So, should you wear pocket squares or not,
the idea of pocket squares is
that this is something that
you might be able to put here
into the pocket of your suit.
So you see this sometimes,
my general recommendation here would be,
to not do it in consulting.
I think it's very unusual,
only very, very few people will do it.
My general recommendation for these
more business type of situations,
would be to not wear pocket squares,
to not use pocket squares like this.
And last but at least,
another point are the watches.
So, think a watch of
course is always something
that nicely compliments a
man's, a gentleman's outfit.
So of course, you need to be a bit careful
with what type of watch you are wearing.
So, what's very popular
and I think no problem
all are smart watches.
So, for instance you own an apple watch
that truly no problem at all
and can also be quite
handy for checking emails,
checking your calendar and so on.
If you want to wear more
traditional mechanical watch,
that's of course, absolutely okay as well,
just two recommendations
that I would give you
from my humble experience is first,
I probably would avoid watches
that cost more than 10,000 Euro or $10,000
or very expensive watches.
Again, in general, you want to
avoid creating the impression
in front of your clients
that you are extremely
rich, extremely loaded.
And then also second, certain brands.
Even though maybe they
are below 10,000 Euro,
just to provide a very general threshold,
they are a bit controversial
and they are associated
with certain thoughts
that some people have.
So, I think you're the
classic one, our Rolex watches
I think in general,
Rolex watches are great,
I can understand why
many people like them.
But maybe if you have one,
rather keep it to yourself
for your leisure time,
maybe with your friends,
if you hang out in the evening,
but maybe not during your work day,
if you work in consulting.
Again this might just create
the wrong impression for you.
And I hope you can see my
point from the beginning
that to say it with Pierre Bourdieu,
the differences can often be quite subtle,
but I would be interested in your opinion.
I mean, do you agree, I'm
in no means wanna claim
that I am the biggest fashion master,
happy to also learn more
about these things from you.
As always, if you took any
value out of this video
at all please hit the like
button for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to stay up
to date with all my content.
Big, big, thanks to all
the members of the channel.
Thank you for supporting the course.
My name is Heinrich,
on my channel, I release
weekly content every Saturday.
So, see again next week
and till then, all the
best for you and bye bye.